il y a des élections dont on connaît à
l'avance le résultat arrivé au pouvoir
il y a maintenant 22 ans le président
tunisien sortant Ben Ali Brig demain un
5e mandat à chacun des scrutins il a
toujours obtenu plus de 90 % des
suffrages ça en dilon sur l'élection de
demain Régis
nousb le président Benali en campagne
électorale à 73 ans il brigue un 5è
mandat à la tête de son pays
et sa réélection ne fait guerre de doute
et pourtant quand il est arrivé au
pouvoir en novembre 1987 après avoir
renversé le vieux président bourgiba
Benali avait promis d'instaurer une
démocratie moderne et l'état de
droit alors 22 ans après lorsque l'on
compare la réalité du pays aux promesses
qui avaient été faites on ne peut que
constater qu'aucune de ces promesses n'a
été tenue et qu'en réalité le président
Benali a fait exactement l'inverse de ce
qu'il avait promis de faire on sait très
bien qu'il y a pas un régime
démocratique qui permet à un président
d'obtenir 99 % des voix le président
Benali sait qu'il peut compter sur
l'appui des occidentaux au premier rang
desquels la France car pour Paris il
représente un rempart contre la menace
islamiste comme est venu le répéter
Nicolas Sarkozi lors de sa visite
officiel l'an dernier en
Tunisie qui peut
penser que l'Europe
je serais plus heureuse avec un régime
taliban en
Algérie en Tunisie sans parler du Maroc
certes la Tunisie affiche des points
positifs l'éducation la santé un taux de
croissance inégalé dans la région et son
statut de la femme héritée de bourgiba
qui fait les Tunisiennes les femmes les
plus émancipées du monde arabe mais
derrière ce bilan apparemment flatteur
se cache une autre réalité la répression
systématique des opposants comme c'est
avocat matraqué en pleine rue la torture
régulièrement dénoncée par les
organisations de défense des droits de
l'homme et une situation sociale parfois
explosive comme dans le bassin minier de
Gafsa au centre du pays secoué l'an
dernier par des mouvements
sociaux officiellement ils sont qure
candidats briguer la présidence mais
dans les fait Benal fa cavalier seul en
compagnie de son épouse dans un scrutin
qui semble jouer
d'avance